anaïs barbeau-lavalette bonsoir
bienvenue forme et issam bon soir
bienvenue vous êtes des complices et
vous avez mis au monde toutes les deux
une aux éoliennes en fait vous avez
faire revivre dans ce magnifique livre
qui est publiée à ce moment ci destinée
aux 5 à 13 ans puis je ne le trouve
toutes les mamans et tous les papas et
vous le dis aussi à toutes les garçons à
tous les gars sont pas toutes les
petites filles staff et anaïs comment
est née la démarche
c'est drôle parce qu'il ya comme une
suite un peu accidenté avec la femme qui
fuit le désir de m'intéresser aux
héroïnes en fait qu'ils sont celles qui
ont été marqueuse de notre histoire puis
qui peuvent être des modèles encore
aujourd'hui l'idée étant de les ancrer
dans quelque chose de réaliste c'est à
dire de ne pas en faire des super
héroïne soient des femmes
super sexy ou des femmes vierges ou
dénoncer des maires et des amoureux des
femmes comme nous oui comme comme nos
mères comme nos voisines comme les
petites filles en devenir donc l'idée
étant de les ancrer dans une féminité
axé sur accessible en mettant sur
plusieurs siècles parce que ça traverse
les siècles de notre histoire des femmes
que l'on est bien si on avait condamné
c'est par notre histoire une histoire
qui souvent oblitéré maintenant il va
marival et on en avait déjà par exemple
entendu parler mais au fil des siècles
une des slavia la première neurologue la
première est trop physicienne la
première femme médecin des femmes sont
victimes d'injustice alors c'est comment
vous avez trouvé ces femmes là comment
de les découvrir ou est-ce qu'on est des
coûts ces femmes là nous de prendre le
relais non aux mesures mais en fait on a
vraiment travaillé ensemble il ya eu
d'abord un rapport de recherche parce
que le ski est à la fois très beau et
tragique c'est qu'il y en a encore des
centaines et des fontaines ans bien
comptés
on les connaît trop peu mais en même
temps en les lisant il ya vraiment eu un
déclic des coups de foudre le vert qui
comment ça se fait qu'on connaît pas
cette femme qui a parcouru des milliers
de kilomètres pour aller sauver le
castor est parce qu elle était très
proche des bris puis elle faisait les
cris sont mes amis
il ya plus de caster les cris vont
mourir elle part en traîneau avec ses
modèles où est mon droit bon aloi
tassant bien québec à l'obtiennent zones
protégées et pour sauver les cartes donc
une aventurière revient pionnière dans
les 40 sur pas trop comment il fait
froid puis elle reste super inspirante à
sa façon ouais donc comment ne procéder
t on ses potes on sait pas à qui ça
prend un éventail
de femme militante syndicaliste d'aider
d'autres madeleine farard en aller à
robert moy aussi le collège joffre
dès l'alerté fermière les femmes de
refus global youth et il ya des artistes
des sportifs dès la première entier
madame il d'ailleurs celle avec 230 deux
premières femmes à montréal elle a gagné
les jeux olympiques de 1932 qui est un
personnage de la femme qui fuit et le
hand façon en pointillés donc un clin
d'oeil aussi on revient la tuer mais
comment vous avez fait le lien avec
mathilde donc que vous êtes une
illustratrice et comment incarner ces
femmes certaines bien sûr madame
casgrain ya des photos qui existent mais
pour toutes les autres
comment avez vous fait pour les abords
des piquets parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de poésie dans le dessin c'est
très douce vraiment carte blanche le
projet dans le fond on ne t'accepte un
peu ensemble pas en même temps on a
monté tout l'ensemble ça fait que c'est
sûr que pour celle que j'avais des
photos d'art chez j'avais vraiment envie
de prendre le parti pris de de prendre
une photo qu'on connaissait quasiment la
plus connue pour que les enfants puis
les adultes qu'elle est lire le livre
puisse les reconnaître après j'avais
envie aussi con que ce soit pas juste
des personnages que ce soit ce soient
des femmes à créer dès que j'ai montré
les images à ma fille c'est ce qui a
modelé à dire à la fois mon éducateur et
leurs femmes à matha ressemble à la
voisine
je me dis oui c'est possible d'ailleurs
vous avez ce livre entre vos mains
depuis quelques jours seulement oui son
petit l'infirmerie vos enfants l'ont
regardé feuilletée qu'est-ce que j'ai
testé évidemment les textes sur mes
enfants alors quand j'étais en écriture
puis j'ai pris le parti de tirer vers le
haut plutôt que vers la bossa au bébé
c'est pas bébé c'est l'fun à lire pour
un parent et je veux dire c'est le fun
quand quand tu sens que tu es dans
l'intimité de la chambre dire qui je
sais que ce que je tenterai une somme et
là ça va dépasser ce soir ça va prendre
moulin à vent debout
vous allez dans les rues un goûter à 3 4
lignes au hasard c'est vrai
en avez-vous une préférée mathilde
mais je n'ai pas eu l'impression que ça
devenait ma préférée là je pense que mme
après c'est sûr qu'il ya des petits
coups de coeur la carie matilda d'eric
elle c'est sûr que ça a été a été relevé
par plusieurs personnes elles reviennent
parce que elle et fait un cours de
botanique
ouais on lui refuse son diplôme parce
que c'est une femme ça aurait été la
première botaniste diplômés pour nous
plus bas d'ailleurs elle va faire partie
en 1901 des 100 hommes de sciences les
plus importants de la planète même pas
reconnu comme tel
oui il ya l'astrophysicienne quand même
les restos physicienne louis alibert
douglas wick et à 6,6 sur venus parce
qu'il ya un cratère de vénus qui porte
son nom
donc elle donc c'est tout ça je me dis
comment ça se fait que même où j'ai deux
mois les parcours ans je faisais leurs
noms ne raisonnait pas ça ne fait pas
partie de mon imaginaire du tout on se
ment ça les enfants c'est des éponges le
joint en compte là il joue demain je
leur lis un peu de tout puis après ils
incarnent ces personnages là donc je me
dis possible de 3 à lingwala
m'étonnerait pas de les voir incarner
ali baddou klein émilie gamelin qu'on
connaît le parc mais que l'on connaît
pas toute son oeuvre elle était le parc
situé dans un endroit il ya beaucoup du
commun pour dire disney à montréal dont
là on retrouve toute son oeuvre dans
cette petite page la wii un film at il
pour vous donc des dessins oui c'est ça
pendant que votre exploit qui le prêtre
qui est à l'aise ici qui s'est quand
même ça peux tu as préféré mathilda dans
les joueurs donc 1862 sa naissance 1941
sa mort petit karim marche lentement
tout le monde lui dit tout le temps à
l'écurie avance mais que lui est très
occupée elle observe les plantes ça
prend du temps observer les plantes
elles sont toutes différentes
certains noms de longues feuilles qui
leur font des bras d'autres ressemblent
un ventre de femme et d'autres avancent
qu'ils rient en place dans l'enfance de
cette femme là qui devient là
la première femme professeur
d'université au québec et en plus on a
beaucoup parlé du frère marie victorin
mais elle est le précède marie-victorin
d'une certaine manière non oui tout à
fait alors oui c'est sûr ça c est plein
de reconnaissance pour lui l'image api
presque les premières à leur école et
vous avez un amour particulier des
fleurs et les fleurs qui illustrent le
livre sont celles des surfeurs oui les
jardins de métis pour laquelle vous avez
une page aussi oui vous l'aimé beaucoup
oui mais comment quand je les hais les
dossiers historiques nos tout petits
coups de coeur lacasse a rejoint nos
intérêts pareil pour les autres femmes
que quand j'en fais une jeudi à celle là
c'est celle à mon ami hoyano dati on
faisait les liens mais c'est sûr que ben
si c'est moi j'ai un peu j'en fais
pousser des flashs un culte est beaucoup
plus sain et et elle a été une pionnière
à faire pousser des espèces qui keepsake
c'est à peu près pas ici plutôt dans son
petit gerben dans cette affaire ils ont
nordique web
et puis ça fait pour vous démontrer que
c'est possible
la première femme médecin première femme
neurologue une série de premières mais
je crois comprendre déposer votre
dernier mot tout les deux jochen
j'imagine va y avoir une suite il
yad'autres 0,1 à venir aïe aïe aïe aïe
initialement à l'appel mais je me dis je
nous invite à découvrir celle là
évidemment parce que parce qu'elles sont
ultra inspirante puis encore très très
très content port et le mauvais rôle
incroyable parce que c'est le goût de
l'audace et le goût de la confiance les
bouts de la liberté de s'affranchir de
tous les obstacles de toutes les
contraintes tous hâte en restant
féminine
on peut être mère on peut être belle on
peut at il donc il ya tout ça dans la
tendresse des traits de mathilde ou si
oui c'est des héroïnes mais elles ont la
tendresse et la beauté et la grandeur
toutes deux féminines de l'homme
d'aujourd'hui alors matt hill 5 mars
anaïs barbeau-lavalette on va souhaiter
une belle vie à ce livre la femme qui
fut est un succès planétaire
n'est ce pas fait oublier le fameux fut
vaut bien je viens et traduit en
plusieurs langues continue sa vie
alors merci pour votre créativité votre
talent
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup